à l'arrêt depuis mi mars les rues de new
york sont toujours quasiment déserte
après l'annnonce du gouverneur andrew
cuomo de prolonger le confinement au
delà du 15 mai le ministre vient tous
les jours en aide aux quelques 80 milles
sdf que compte la ville la station de
métro entre chaînes et la ligne e eux se
sont au fil des jours transformé en
refuge pour cette partie de la
population fortement susceptibles de
contracter la maladie
il nous parle de distanciation sociale
mais pourquoi j'irais dans un refuge
alors qu'il ya vingt personnes qui
dorment dans une seule pièce
alors je dors dans le train où que je
sois je m'endors habitue à patrouiller
dans les rues de la ville pour veiller à
la sécurité des passants les guardian
angels ont modifié leur activité pour
s'occuper à temps plein des sdf
le confinement a considérablement réduit
la vie urbaine et pour ceux qui
survivent grâce à la mendicité laitance
mots particulièrement durs
les salariés de la ville qui normalement
s'occupe des sdf ont peur ils sont en
isolement chez eux
les bureaux sont fermés certains sdf en
70 ans
quel genre de pays on est on est le pays
le plus riche du monde
en temps normal on les laisse vivre
dehors et maintenant on les a
complètement abandonné à manhattan
le refuge borie qui existe depuis 140
ans à aider les new yorkais a traversé
de nombreuses crises notamment celle de
la grippe espagnole de 1918 aujourd'hui
le refuge tente tant bien que mal
d'apporter son aide aux personnes dans
le besoin tout en assurant la protection
de sa communauté
plus de gens qu'avant qui viennent ici
pour essayer d'obtenir de quoi se
nourrir
il ya par ailleurs beaucoup moins de
rupture parce que je pense qu'une grande
penser qu'une grande partie de la
nourriture avant mener des listes
ce mois ci devant l'absence de
structures mises en place pour les sdf
plus de 500 médecins physicien et
infirmiers new yorkais ont signé une
lettre demandant au maire et au
gouverneur de créer des espaces
d'isolation pour les sdf positif au
courant des virus et où ils ne peuvent
pas se protéger comme les autres qui ont
le privilège de pouvoir s'isoler
viennent à l'hôpital ils sont dans les
urgences et une autre source
d'exposition and we have to be on doit
les faire sortir parce qu'on a aucun
endroit dédié plusieurs personnalités
politiques de new york ont fait appel au
gouverneur andrew cuomo lui demandant de
fermer temporairement le métro afin de
limiter la transmission du collier
quant aux associations de défense des
sans abri elle dénonce le manque de
réaction du maire bill de blasio pour
protéger les sdf et lui demande de
mettre à disposition trente mille
chambres d'hôtel au lieu des 2500 prévue
à la fin du mois d'avril